so last year I'm here and there was a
couple man or woman they were they were
just like kissing and hugging all night
and I'm like this is a nice couple you
know
and I say to them I'm talking I say to
my ghost you got kids and they were like
yeah I go how old are your kids
and they tell me and I go that's cool I
go and I asked him another question
about their kids and the guy goes yeah
we got kids but not together
I go oh
he goes we're actually we're married to
other people foreign
he goes yeah yeah we have kids but with
other people we're married to other
people now what I thought was
they were both separated and they had
gotten together and that was their cute
way of their entry into we're separated
whatever you know
so I said oh I go you guys are married
to other people I go oh I said but but
like
the other people know you guys are here
together right
and the guy goes I [__] hope not
yo this whole the whole room was like
what the [__] do we do with this what do
we what
people were not sure whether to laugh or
whether to be like what is happening
right now and
he thought it was way funnier than she
did uh and so uh
I said to where I go wait I go
you're the other people don't know
you're here together
the guy goes no
and I go yo dude I go obviously you live
your life the way you want to live your
life but like
it's kind of ballsy talking about that
in front of a room
full of people
and he goes like this to me he goes
he looks behind him and he goes
I live an hour from here I don't know
any of these people
they're sitting right here yo from the
darkness from back there I just hear
somebody scream I know you mark
thank you
Mark's butthole was like
[Laughter]
yeah I was like oh Mark you better enjoy
this night because the rest of them are
gonna be [__] from here on up
you follow me you know how much I like
weird [__] and so I I because of that it
shows up on my shows and so the latest
weird thing I can't get into all the
weird things that have happened recently
because they do I don't know did you see
a video I posted from last week where
that lady took her eyeball out anybody
see that video
came on stage and just went up and I was
like did you just take your eye out
so I like it a little bizarre right so
but somebody asked me what was my
favorite crazy weird thing that's
happened recently and I will tell you so
I was in Dallas Texas there was a dude
sitting right where you are bro and he
was wearing a kilt
and I said to him I go hey man I go
what's with that kill and he said oh I
wrestle and he's Texas I wrestle in the
small little circuit you know and he had
red beard and red hair and he said I I
do the whole leprechaun thing
I go that's cool I go and we were
talking a little bit dude real
gregarious guy and I go that's awesome
man I go so did you you get the kilt on
you must have wrestled tonight and then
he goes no
I said so what's with the kill and he
started doing this
[Music]
and he said things get a little sticky
here in Dallas and I was like
didn't need the visual but I got you I
know what you're saying to me right now
but I'm a very uh Curious person man and
I like talking to people and I like
asking people questions and if you're
wearing a kilt and you're doing this
I got one question right off the top of
my head so I asked them I go wait a
second dude are you in the front row the
comedy show we're in a kilt are you not
wearing underwear
and he looked at me and he goes
I'll tell you what I tell everybody else
you're gonna lift it up to find out
I said I might tell you something
you're challenging the wrong guy
[Laughter]
so I said yeah I'll lift up that kill
and he told me he goes you know I've
told about a thousand people with the
list killed and nobody ever has
and I said well
you're gonna learn today
and he said okay and he spread his legs
and he said get in there
which was kind of aggressive I thought
you know what I mean and he was trying
to make me uncomfortable so I wouldn't
lift his killer and look you can't try
to make me uncomfortable at my show I
have to make you more uncomfortable than
you've made me right so when he said get
in there I just dropped to my knees just
like this
and right when I did he leaned back and
he went why are you doing that
I said I'm gonna lift the kill he goes
yeah but do you have to do it from your
knees
and I said well
and my experience it's the best angle to
see a dick so
foreign
if you're gonna do this you got to keep
eye contact with me I'm like
yo this dude would not I [__] hated
him
he wouldn't let me win every time I
tried to make him uncomfortable he was
like nah I'm on how uncomfortable you
right so he made him so he was like
stare into my eyes so I'm staring at
this dude right reaching for his kill
now I gotta tell you guys on the outside
that was cool it's a cucumber
on the inside
yes you know when you're so nervous that
you can feel your heartbeat in your
butthole
you know when your asshole's gasping for
breath like get us out of here why are
we still here get us out of here come on
so I reached out and I just
now does anybody have any Kilt knowledge
in here
yeah okay oh you don't okay what I
didn't know about the kill is that
there's two sides of the kill and one
side when you lift it up it's just more
killed that's the side I lifted up first
and he just leaned back and he went
whoopsie
he said I bury the treasure on the other
side
I reached out and I reached for his kill
one last time and right when I do this
[__] pink Winks at me
I'm like I hate you so much
and I just
yeah human dick real dick yeah
and it was a red-headed situation I'd
never seen one of those before
yo it was so much brighter than I
thought it was gonna be
I'm not gonna lie to you it looked
irritated is what it did
it looked like someone ran over just
went and just hit it one time
and this dude was all potatoes no meat
he
foreign
bubble just
I like to ask this question every time
that I come here every time I come I
make sure that I finish that sentence
because I know the people who come to
see my shows and somebody was going to
call me that was anybody here here a few
years back when I was here and those
people were fingering each other
were you at that show
you were the show after was anyone at
that show
yeah so first of all you heard that show
you were here first of all it happened
at that table no pressure but uh
[Applause]
we're all looking for a little
entertainment from you guys so
it was the crate was it one of the
craziest
foreign
like one of the reasons I love coming
here is because every time I come here
something really [__] weird
[Music]
and I love we smear [__] I love it I
love it I love it so just so you know no
pressure but here's what happened okay
by the way man good hair look at this
guy oh
oh [__]
my job not a hair out of place a little
bit hanging down I like it do you do a
hair flip in the morning or no do you
tell me tell me tell me I have terrible
Jew fro hair I've never been able to do
a hair flip in my life I go like this
and my hair goes like that you know what
I mean
so you yeah you got is this your
girlfriend sister wife I don't know I'm
in Utah I don't know your friend
and who's this behind you here
that's your girlfriend
and that is
your your girlfriend's father is here
[Applause]
I think I can speak for all the fathers
when I tell you he doesn't trust you
[__] foreign
[Applause]
how do you fit in
that's your best friend
so your girlfriend brought her best
friend and her father on the date with
you
hi what's that
he bought the tickets how long have you
guys been dating
six months
you know what's crazy you've been
together six months you've been together
21 years can I tell you something they
said something to each other on the car
ride over that would end your [__]
relationship
you know there is a level of honesty at
this table you guys don't even know
anything about hey it's some sometime
this week one of you two looked at the
other was like I [__] hate you so
much and the other one was like I don't
give a [__] whatever come on let's go
you're not going anywhere
I have to pretend to like
it
wow okay so he bought the tickets
for you or for the two of you how did
that work for her and then okay all
right
well sir I didn't know if I don't know
if you if on purpose did you spend extra
for the finger bang table or was that
where you're like where do they finger
bang what is the part of the floor where
there's gonna be some finger banging
happening because
let's see if we can ruin this six month
relationship by the end of this show
I mean I got 50 minutes I'm pretty good
at this
I'm gonna tell you guys what happened
I'll tell you what happened
so
tell me and how many I may forget
something so if you can think of a
pertinent part of the story raise your
hand and I'll
and I'll uh ignore you
um so um
no so I'm sitting here and uh there were
four people sitting this table two
couples and I thought they were together
but you know the so say you and the
friend you were the couple and you were
facing me and the other two were also
facing me but behind them and he when I
because somebody said well how did you
know he was
finger banging her and you can attest to
this guys he he wasn't subtle it wasn't
they were sitting almost as far apart as
you two were and the best way I can
describe it
is it he looked like a DJ scratching a
record like
there were zero subtlety in his movement
he didn't give a [__] that anybody else
was here
now uh one of the weight staff asked me
after the show how come you didn't say
anything and I will tell you the truth
it just gave me something different to
look at you know what I mean
I'm so used to seeing this when I was
like okay I'll look at that for a little
while and it was right in front of me
and he was making eye contact with me
and I was like
this dude is a baller he's just like
what man what like nothing dude nothing
it was a [__] real prison move you
know what I mean like
and now he did end up getting kicked out
he got kicked out he got kicked out
because he was talking to the stable and
I can't have that uh
yeah listen you're your finger and your
girlfriend you're not bothering anybody
else you know what I mean it's not
disruptive to the show but talking at
your table is so just so you know for
the future if you come to my shows
finger Blast away but keep it down
so I ended up kicking him out and I
think we named him the finger bangers
didn't we on Mr and Mrs finger banger
and um so they're walking up and the guy
turned out to be a real [__] yeah he
was a
um
um and so
I gotta tell you something that I found
out after the show
remind me okay I'm not going to tell you
after the show I found out after I'll
tell you okay so
the guy they walk out and I'm just like
did nobody else
see that because they were in wide open
like this and about 60 of the crowd was
like no we fucking's hot nothing oh my
God
oh my God right
and we had a good laugh and now the
couple who was sitting behind him I had
to ask because the I thought they were
together I go oh you guys weren't
together and the woman goes no
I can't believe I had to sit at this
table
and the guy goes I can't believe I
didn't have to pay extra for the ticket
[Applause]
how about this you know what I found out
after
they split up after they were both
on a secret date the reason he was mad
is either they were both married to
somebody else or both dating other
people so he was mad because I put him
on blast
but you can't come out in public and
finger bang your mistress in front of
full
keep it down man I'm trying to be subtle
like no bro
you're wiki wiki not you know what I
mean
foreign
but uh no pressure
[Applause]
um
dad you should sit this one out but uh
you know I'm saying he
yeah he's like I can't believe I bought
tickets for this [__] show and I sat
at this table
what strikes me at the airport a lot
guys is if
it seems like
it flies in here a lot
you just one quiet me
are you sitting under the chair holy
[__]
that sounded like your last breath
he said that
how far back eight miles holy [__] all
right are you you're the does anybody
else so for me what strikes me about the
airport is always so weird and can I
know you fly a lot
um is that
people forget it seems like people
forget they're in public
do you know what I mean like they're
they free I don't know if they have
their headphones on so they think nobody
can see me you know
but so I'm in the airport
and at the airport is where I like to
look for weird things
because the airport is where I see a lot
of weird [__] guys a lot a lot a lot
[Music]
what strikes what catches my eye first
is this gentleman uh probably mid 60s
he's reading a book like this
why that gets me right away is because
this is how my dad reads a book
okay and I'm gonna tell you something
about my dad my dad is and for those who
know what I'm talking about my dad is
from a generation of guys who are just
gentlemen
just [__] gentlemen and anything that
I associate with my dad I associate with
class and being a gentleman and my dad
still dresses up to go to the airport
yeah man I hear you I mean that's right
I show up high in sweatpants you know
what I mean
my dad's a classy dude he's a gentleman
man and so and also he still reads books
he doesn't like to read Kindle he
doesn't read he wants to read a book he
likes to text you he likes the tan the
textile stuff and so he's holding it
like this and I and the dude's dress
nice and I'm like look at this gentleman
we should have more guys like this
hanging out at the airport and I just
start to scan the air nothing nothing
let me check Vicky check back in with my
gentlemen
I checked back in and now this dude
is doing this
reading like this still like this with
this hand
with this hand at this point the hand is
right here moving very slowly this
slowly
back like this
and I'm like
what is happening yeah I had that exact
look on my face dude
right like what right he goes like this
and he lifts up a little bit and he
sneaks his hand under and I'm like oh
he's gonna do a little little digging
you know
and I'm here for a dig I'll watch you
know uh
I I look I I know I know I know I know
and I'll tell you why I'll tell you why
you judgey I'll tell you why
I don't like to see the Dig itself if
I'm if I need to explain myself I will I
don't really need I don't know I don't
care about the Dig truthfully
I just want to see what you do with your
hand afterwards that's it
I want to know if I need to call the
health board if I need to wash something
I need to know where this dirty [__] is
going right so I'll take a look this
dude digs and I'm gonna tell when I tell
you he he was there for longer than he
should be he was
and I'm watching him the whole way no
expression change on his face no nothing
and and he comes out guys
he comes out with his hand like this
now guys he went in like this out like
this
that means he's got
yeah he's got a plan
I believe the police would call this
intent
he he comes out like this
and then goes just like this
and I'm watching him like oh no no no no
no no no no no
does anyone want to get
again but he did
sniffs okay anyone else want to guess
Turn the Page
foreign
he didn't do that but the next time I
tell the story he will I'll tell you
that right now
that's funny as [__] man
yeah he's like I need to [__] flip
yeah oh boy he goes
and by the way the first thing I think
is as he's getting closer I'm like
am I about to watch
the very first ever self-inflicted dirty
Sanchez in the history
you know dirty sanchez yourself
I'm like what is going on I'm I'm just
I can't figure out where and he's moving
so [__] slowly
I'm like is he torturing me on purpose
just this
and my man he just goes he goes just I
guess he goes
like if chapstick had a butt butter like
so I right when I see it I think to
myself who else saw this
because this is the kind of person I am
guys I'm an Arms Wide Open guy if we're
laughing I want us to laugh together if
I see something weird I want us to enjoy
this together it's just who I am right
so I'm looking through the airport like
I can't be the only person who saw this
I can't nobody nothing nobody nothing
nobody nothing until sitting right
across from me
there was a woman
eating her salad
like this
[Laughter]
and I just screamed over to her I go hey
hey
right
and she just threw her fork in her bowl
and she across the airport she screams
[__] yuck
I was like yeah you're not wrong is it a
spider
yeah
it didn't look small
yeah yo when that thing comes down I bet
you it [__] makes it like a Batman
thing across the wall that's for you all
right and did he come down
how far how far down you can put your
phone down
you want to touch my head and nobody
decided to kill it
[Laughter]
yeah this dude looks tough and I was
like spider he's like [__] not me are
you okay
what if I was just like
live live insects before I'm live on um
I did a TV show a live show on Discovery
once where I I had to eat live
cockroaches
it's online it's pretty gross uh
all right
Spider-Man
I mean
who'd have thought we'd all just be
staring at a [__] spider
[Laughter]
[Applause]
like nobody's ever seen one before I
don't know
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
's tatted up from [__] neck to ankle
bearded up big dude [__] is that a
spider
that's not what I was expecting from you
man you know
that's awesome do you see he moved her
in front of him he was like
that's awesome man
I'm the same way dude
congratulations
you just saved her life
[Applause]
well you know what I do love about how
you were reacting
you had everywhere to go you could have
gone right and you just went against
just
like like that's three inches was gonna
be like
he didn't want to interrupt me you
didn't think you're doing this ah wasn't
interrupting me
it's totally okay guys you have to
understand man
this type of [__] is what I love about
my job
my job is never the same this that's
never gonna happen again that's never
gonna happen again either
[Applause]
I have a very anxious dog
here we go
I mean he's not as anxious as this guy
around spiders but he's pretty
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you took an empty one away and you put
another full one down
wow yeah okay hey everybody you know
you know a little later
okay we're just
take it down
I have a feeling it's not the last time
I'm gonna have to talk to you three
I will be taking my edible right now
um
now I don't like to take him off stage
because I like you guys to see that oh I
thought the cops were coming uh
I was like that was quick holy [__]
my reputation precedes me all right
every time she did I was like tip of the
hat to you
foreign
like he hadn't breathed there
[Music]
and I think you should stop asking me
stupid [__] questions
[Music]
but oh yeah this is the Late Show so I
can tell you this okay
so he developed a nickname that night
[Music]
you probably get here
yeah
we're good we're good
it's time it's time it's time
yeah that's good
no no no
no no no no no
um
it's totally good it's totally good
all right
all right everybody it's okay it's all
right sorry I love how the murmur spread
across the crowd and murmur
Ray
I I um I I know you're wondering because
I could hear that what that [__] what
the [__] up
I was trying because she was being a
soldier this one in the middle I was
trying to let it go because she was
trying to play it off but she's been
throwing up in that glass
for the last 15 minutes that is not
drink that's vomit
but I was like oh look at she's
soldiering on because she was doing it
quiet none of you knew huh
she was due go yo I [__] loved it
yeah guys I'm telling you I love weird
[__] I the reason I the only reason I
said it's time to go is because the
glass is full I didn't wanted her
I didn't want her to throw up on the
[__] ground you know
I was just trying to be nice to the
staff but if she had a bigger glass
believe me she would still be here
yeah I like that [__] that doesn't
bother me at all it just gives me
something different to look at I don't
usually see that you know
you know what I'm saying I'm totally
good with that that was and by the way
this is how she it like a [__]
Soldier she was doing this she would go
right so she would just go
and I was like this [__] means
for real
I was like she is a [__] OG
[Applause]
[Music]
but I was just like yo if she's in it to
win it I'm who am I to kick her out you
know what I mean
she's going a hundred I'm going 100 with
her
I can't believe you didn't know she was
throwing up right next to you
that's because I mean how would you know
like a [__] bird or something like
she was feeding your kid um
no that's totally okay you don't have to
apologize it was really funny I was
thoroughly enjoying myself
I I mean guys guys I was looking down
and then looking around like am I the
only one who knows
oh yeah I was like this is the most
stealth
repeated projectile vomit
like I don't even know that if that was
an Olympic sport gold [__] metal
tonight
damn
you think being a ventriloquist is hard
try filling up a large glass of vomit
in front of 300 people and not have
anyone know
David Copperfield who you know
all right
that was so good
can I tell you guys so I was in I was in
um I was in Cleveland and
um right about where this couple is
right here okay so I was in Cleveland
right about where this couple is here
there's a couple and they're just like
you they're facing towards me and
they're at a four top a round table and
there's two people behind them they're
facing me too
so the people in front the dude is full
on finger banging her right
full on now your hands up yeah
[Applause]
not this dude not this dude
no uh
yeah so full on and guys not like a um
there was no none there's no subtlety to
this they were
not close to each other
so there was a space between them so he
had to reach his uh
yeah he okay I'm gonna say something
terrible
but I'm on stage and he
[Music]
he looked like he was a DJ scratching a
record like that
that's how subtle he was being in a
crowd full of people
and I'm on stage just like and but I had
the same attitude like I never see this
that's
I mean I there's so much you see all the
time so when you see something different
you're like okay I'll take a look at
that okay
I didn't want to watch her through if
you said do you want to watch someone
throw up tonight I'd have been no but
when it was happening I'm like that's
kind of cool
you know
full on did you dig it dig it right
and so uh
and eventually it ends and you know look
the truth of the matter is what do I
care
you know what do I I don't what do I
care he's not bothering anybody nobody's
saying anything so I don't care right
but then he started talking at the at
his table
and
um and that I don't that I'm not okay
with you know
because that's disrupting the show for
other people and so I told him you know
you got a quiet town and he was and he
said something like just keep going with
your little thing and I was like
and I was like yeah man this is not
gonna this is I already know this is not
going to end well for us like I I said
here's what's gonna happen I just want
to tell you right up front like
you're disrupting a show for other
people so it's my job to ask you to
quiet down
and he said and it's my job to tell you
I'll do what I want and I was like well
now you gotta go man I said you got to
go you gotta get out of here and take
your finger Banger with you and
right and because I didn't think anyone
else saw it as soon as I said it the
entire crowd jumped up and they were
like that [__] happened
like there was pandemonium in the crowd
people the people out there was a
there's a balcony the people the balcony
like we [__] saw that
this poor lady was just like oh my God
the dude this will tell you exactly what
kind of dude this was there are 400
people jumping around chanting finger
bangers finger bangers
has her jacket over her head dude is
like this
and I was like that is the exact guy who
would finger bang someone in public yep
boom
hey everybody
I hope everyone had a
time tonight
yo I am can't wait to tell that story on
stage [__]
are you kidding me
she uh you know what by the way you know
what else was really good she would do
the super drunk person uh face wipe you
know when they go it's like a long hard
wipe it's this
foreign
you get all the way into the [__]
elbow you're like
[Music]
uh I had drunk people make me laugh man
I know I get super high but drunk people
you know what drunk people this is your
favorite move
drunk people's two favorite moves the
first one is the wall wing
like somehow you think leaning on a wall
is gonna make you look more [__]
sober but the other one that's my
favorite because it's it should be way
easier than you're making it is the
[__] hand on the hips
what the [__] is going on you know
oh they're gonna want me to leave here
pretty soon
huh
what are you saying to me right now
because I think I understood all the
words
individually
but when you ran them all together in
that sentence I didn't understand what
the [__] you said at all
yeah I'm good I'm good I'm good thanks
we got this dog man
I like to smoke weed but I
mean I also like to smoke weed when I
don't walk my dog
but I'm out High walking my dog one
night and um
and uh so my dog is a weird he's a weird
pooper
I don't know if does anybody have a
pitbull London a green here hippo and so
does he does he poop normal like on flat
ground
yeah
yeah okay
she the stares at you that's all dogs do
I think they all stare at you it's just
really prison [__] you know what I mean
you know
you're eyeballing someone when you're
taking a shoot you're like that's right
keep looking all right
but I will tell you something you know
um my dog first of all it's always weird
when I walk him because he doesn't poop
normal
he he first there's only three places
he'll put with it he'll be a poop on top
of a giant rock is his favorite one if
he can find a giant rock he will pull me
over there get to the very edge of it
like [__] Simba just and [__]
[Music]
it's so weird and then when he poops on
a rock nowhere else he walks around it a
couple times
the other two places he'll poop is he'll
poop up a tree
is
it hides up against and he lifts his ass
up so his fronts are off the ground his
butthole is against the tree and he
poops so it sticks to the tree
it's the craziest the first time I saw
him do it I'm like are you [__] like
what are you doing
he shits up trees and then he looks at
like well you take a picture of
everything else you're not gonna take a
picture of that
my favorite place where he poops and
this is my wife and I both call him the
bush poop he poops on bushes
his his favorite thing is to find a
little Bush and poop on top of it like
it like it like a topping of a sundae or
something
but what I think is his like mischievous
part of him
is when he poops in the bush the bigger
Bush he'll put his butt in there
and and when he you know how pitbulls
smile
so he'll poop in the bush and smile at
me like
you're gonna put your hand in here
and so one night he [__] to the bush
and um and by the way I'm with you on
nope I don't do a lot of impersonation
guys let me give you my one
impersonation that I do do I said dude
um it's an impersonation of me
trying to decide if I'm going to pick up
my dog's poop in a bunch okay this is me
if I don't see anybody I know I'm not
picking up that [__] that's how that
goes right so [__] that I'm not working
for it you know if it's on the ground
fine but I'm not rolling up my sleeves
you know so I look I see someone I know
I'm like damn it I reach in the bush and
I'm high I pick it up I throw it away I
start to walk down the street
and I'm about 20 minutes from my house
and I just itch my ear a little bit
oh it gets so much worse
and I'm like do I have earwax in my ear
and I take my finger out and there's a
little bit of poop because when I guess
when I reach the bush I got a little
poop on my finger now I want you to
think about how you scratch your ear do
you caress it you don't you know what
you do you jam you jam I jammed dog [__]
into my head I jammed it if I had tried
to push it in harder I couldn't have I
jammed dog [__] into my ear like I was
trying to do it
and so guys my paranoia I'm high so my
paranoia is like
feel the worms swimming to my brain
I myself 20 minutes to live I'm like are
you guys 20 minutes to live you know so
I start to walk home
and I'm in guys I almost dialed 9-1-1 by
the way
the most embarrassing 9-1-1 call ever
like 9-1-1 what's your emergency in my
ear all right we're gonna let you go now
uh
there's a Google search on my phone it
just says it's dog [__] bad for your
brain
Google was like ask Yahoo we don't know
the answer to that question that's so
stupid
but so the only thing that I knew that
was working still guys was grabbing so I
started walking down the street like
this walking my dog
and I'm walking through my neighborhood
I'm trying to get home
20 minutes to live
and I come up on this dude's house and
he's in his front yard he's watering the
little yard he's got a mask on
8 30 at night mask on water in the yard
now guys during this past year we've
been asked to choose from pretty two
stupid teams about this whole pandemic
team it's totally fake and team we're
all gonna die and I'm here to tell you
there's a lot of room in the middle for
smart people you know what I mean
he's on team we're all going to die you
know and so the last thing he wants to
see is my [__] dumb ass walking up to
his
walking up to his house you know
and so he's watering his lawn and he's
like
what's going on
and I was like I need to use your house
and he goes why and I was like like a
dog [__] in my ear
lay the hose down he walked over to his
phone he picked it up and he leaned on
his house and he goes how about it
and I said I would really prefer if you
didn't film this and he said oh I bet
you would
and he goes like are you still not
filming man even though I asked you not
to film it and he goes let me ask you
something if stranger showed up at your
house in the middle of the night and no
[__] in their ear
and says they wanted to wash it out into
your front yard you wouldn't film it
and I was like well not if you ask me
not to but he goes yeah well
that's the price of a mission you want
to use a hose or not
yeah I want to use those man he goes
cool and so I pick up the house
and I have my I'm going to put my thumb
over it and shoot the water into my ear
right
water here done right
and he goes what's the plan it's your
strategy and I go I'm going to shoot the
water into my hair and wash it out he
goes okay he goes you're not scared
you're just gonna shoot the [__] further
into your head
well I am now man
you got this okay I'm gonna pick up the
house and I'm about to shoot the water
into my ear and the Sun comes to the
window of the house and he goes who's
that and he goes oh it's just a friend
who needs to use a house
he goes why does he need to use those
he goes
here
she goes why is here when the guy goes
don't do drugs son
I'm in the middle of um
the last time I was here must have been
a couple years ago
um I got chased by those [__] swans
out front
so
there so I didn't know a whole lot about
swans right and I was looking at him I
was like that bird I got and I was like
what a pretty bird what a pretty bird
and there was somebody who was working
here was like
this the swan
and I go yeah I go you know what's so
crazy they don't they don't fly away
when people come up are they cool if you
pet him and he was like yeah you should
go touch it
he he was lying
because I walked up I don't know
I walked up to that swan
and I was you know okay so
I'm just who I am if it's a wild animal
I'm
I'm not gonna I'm a little nervous
anyways I'm not I'm not
yeah I'm not those people like
all those videos online are the people
like it Yosemite and the grizzly bear
comes and they're like hey [__] bear
and every time I go I hope that bear
[__] eats your face you dumb [__]
so I walk up to the Swan and I was like
hey
foreign
have you seen those
when they do that [__] thing it's
like my college girlfriend when she got
mad you [__] [__]
this thing started swinging its giant
[__] Dome at me I was like holy [__]
so I mental note right
don't [__] with swans right
well apparently
geese are in that same category
so I was out in St Louis and
um I was with my dog we were on a road
trip together and
um by the way this dude uh he's half
bulldog half uh half American bulldog
half pit and he's just a good looking
dude but he had never been on a road
trip and we had never gone out and so we
stopped on the side of the road together
to pee and um I'm peeing and he was
super curious
and was standing there and just walked
right in front of me and turned his face
right into my [__]
yeah I mean he was just like ah yeah
yeah that's what that tastes like all
right yeah
and so he but he was really curious
about those geese and so there was there
was a field full of geese next to the
hotel
and um
they were just like super chill and he
was running around you know I was
throwing a ball and [__] and he kept
looking over the geese like you mind if
I
thank you
mind if I run over there
and I had heard about geese [__]
people up
so I was like
yeah I'd like to see that
I mean I know who my money's on but I I
don't know for sure you know
so he starts to run over right
oh yeah yeah
yo he starts to run over and he was so
you know how pit bulls are kind of have
that smile
right and he was running over and he
even turned over his shoulder smiling
his tongue went out of his mouth and he
was like I'm gonna [__] them up
he was so confident and he started to
run at him right and this is not a small
dog and he's [__] fine yeah
and so he's running these geese across
the field and there was probably I don't
know 15 of them and 13 of them flew away
and two of them turned around and
started to run at him and I was like
foreign
he had the same look on his face he was
going on Full Speed but when they turned
and started to run at him he started to
slow down like what the [__] is it
and then they got probably within 20
yards and they got up on their little
and they you know you know
you know when they go Karate Kid on here
and both the geese just [__]
like that yo this dude went from Full
Sprint to uh
he put the brakes on did one of those
wide turns and started running back at
me yo if he could have spoke this is
what he would have been screaming start
the man
start the [__] man you know what I
mean
he he was scared out of his mark
[Music]
[Applause]
what would be the one word you would use
to describe your dance style
[Applause]
[Music]
and my initials are BBC
okay what would you say is the name
of your bed stands
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
over here
[Applause]
did you just take your [__] eye out
I think you showed a nipple you might
win
[Music]
I don't want to tip your hand but I
think maybe it may be a mini nipple
might get you a big gummy around this
one
[Music]
thank you
you are
my heart
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah no I have bigger Aerials than I
should have that's why I was like I bet
you he's got some media area
and you [__] just yeah yours are so
much better than mine ah all right
listen and that was
awesome
and since it was so awesome
I think both of you are just gonna win
[Applause]
[Music]
if you argue with a teenage girl
she will make you question your life
choices
[Laughter]
your feelings
hold on one second you guys you guys you
guys okay
you good man you good
I've never heard someone discuss a
dessert so [__] loudly before in my
entire life
yeah dude we each get a bite we no you
get a bite and then I get a bite we each
get a bite take it easy there big fella
all right you were [__] we were
getting heated you're getting sweaty on
the top of your head this is my [__]
bite right here I want the end bite all
right we got it dude yeah yeah I didn't
know there was such heated dessert rules
over here all right let's just if you
could just keep your dessert talk to
just a little quieter that would be
great I appreciate it very much you were
[__] listen nobody get in the way of
this dude's dessert you know what I'm
saying there's some serious dessert
rules going over here
yeah it know this it was a serious
conversation I'm glad I broke it up you
almost took your glasses off you're like
I got the first [__] bite
I ordered this [__] I get the
first bite
[Music]
yeah just just in case you didn't know
you were six inches from the stage
did you somehow think nobody would hear
you screaming about your [__] cake
[Laughter]
you think you're in the cones of Islands
[__] you're out in public bro
these people heard you're over here
they're like let me eat the cake for
[__]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah Sam you know that cake better be
good I'll tell you what
oh the edible is creeping up yeah it is
a little bit
I wasn't expecting no don't don't not
eat on my account man look at him now
you see him now he's eating like he's
super polite he's like
oh you got more cake coming yeah
oh that one's not yours that's a problem
and they put it in front of you and
you're like that's not my [__] cake
yeah all right
I get it now and so you don't want to
eat that cake why don't you move it then
from the front of your [__] face oh
yeah okay
[Laughter]
I mean you could have fooled me it
wasn't your cake it was eight inches
from your [__] mouth the whole time
we were talking
yeah you could have just pushed it away
what you didn't want to touch it is that
the whole thing this isn't my cake this
is my [__] cake
why did she put this cake in front of me
this wasn't my cake is that what it was
what cake are you getting I'm just
curious
chocolate souffleck again is it coming
out
oh yeah
I can't wait for that cake to come out
here
what's your name Man Mark dude I have
enjoyed this conversation more than you
could possibly ever imagine
foreign
for here on out people are going to be
like were you at that cake show in
Naples
are you Mark's wife
no
are you here with Mark
okay yeah
has he exhibited this type of aggressive
behavior
around cake before I don't know if it's
an issue
laughs
Mark puts on that cake heat boy
all right listen by the way I'm buying
that cake for you by the way whatever
that is whatever that souffle is uh well
I'm gonna buy that when I mean I'm gonna
buy it you guys pick up the tab for that
I appreciate that
[Applause]
so you see you're texting you're gonna
miss all the [__] cake talk there you
go put your [__] phone down
put your [__] phone down put your
phone down put your phone down put your
phone down oh [__]
unless you're yeah that's you're texting
somebody this [__] cake thing is
amazing I don't wanna
[Applause]
I said to him I know he wants to kill
and he said I wrestled he wrestles in
East Texas where these little circuits
you know YouTube I don't think so do you
what are your what's your wrestling now
shotgun Remington coal
cult
get the [__] out of here right now now
if I bring you on stage can you show me
a move
get the [__] up here
tell me a little bit about your
character tell me uh I'm a Hunter
oh my [__] right
[Applause]
it was a bow and arrow
can you show me something without
killing me
I don't have a whole lot of confidence
in this guy
I didn't see what I asked him that did
he seem super confident what I was like
can you do something without killing me
he kind of struck his shoulders like
yeah
okay what are we gonna do can you show
me a move without me just a solo move
[Music]
to disfigure my son just for the [__]
event yes I will no
[Applause]
um
so here's the deal I'm in between I'm
letting him do something how long does
it shut up from the [__] time I love
people from 100 yards away
[Applause]
what are you wearing in the ring
uh Titans and I'll put even smaller
types of them are long tights tights
over tights
and so if we're gonna do this move are
you gonna are you gonna just roam at all
are you going straight you're not when
you wrestle in front of people you
wrestle with your shirt off though right
[Applause]
I'll take mine off too you be the Earth
before we do this
[Music]
those guys
standing next to each other Ruby like
hey
so what's the plan what are we gonna do
suplex
you first bro are you kidding me right
now A suplex
let's do the one where he breaks your
neck I'd love to see that one I'll come
up here for a second
okay
okay so this is Remington cult
he's a he's a professional wrestler we
were thinking about going shirtless and
doing a wrestling move how do you feel
about that I heard you call me out here
and then I saw you guys about take your
shirts off so I'm probably just gonna go
back later
[Music]
now listen guys
you ready
[Applause]
this is interesting
let me tell you something right now you
know we can be wrestling Twins and be
the meaty nipple Brothers
do you need a little Trash Talk
I'm about to chop the redness all over
yourself
[Applause]
where's trash chunk I've ever heard
that's the lightest
I if it hits me okay bye
I'd put you in the spot yeah man this is
live all right here we go all right uh I
ain't ready to control
[Applause]
hey first of all
that hurt more than I thought
foreign
our nipples are going to be on the
internet
well last night we had we I was sure it
was on stage with this dude who said he
was a professional wrestler and I said
do a move on me and he wound up like
this
and just
guys I have a I have a hand Mark like
yeah yeah you know in first grade when
they were like you get Thanksgiving you
know they draw a turkey that's what I
have
I could draw a turkey on my chest right
now there's a [__] legit thumbprint
I'm like damn if he was a murderer you
could get his prints off of my chest
and you need you pretty hard real hard
you took it Like A Champion I like to
smoke weed bring it
I like to smoke weed
I like to smoke weed bring it
[Applause]
hmm